nous sommes en direct avec arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire à ses côtés
également françois boulot avocat et
gilet jaune bonsoir à tous les deux
merci d'être en direct sur rt france
pour commenter donc ce nouveau
gouvernement castex qui a été dévoilé
aux alentours de 19 heures arnaud
benedetti on commence par vous d'une
manière globale
que vous inspire ce gouvernement est ce
que vous même vous avez eu des surprises
ce soir
sur le fond c'est un gouvernement de
continuité où on a un président de la
république qui finalement poursuit la
ligne est la sienne qui évacuent un
certain nombre de ministres qui étaient
les ministres en difficulté je pense aux
ministres à l'intérieur je pense à la
porte avant le gouvernement je pense à
la garde des sceaux et qui disons sur le
plan de la symbolique va chercher
quelques personnalités médiatiques qui
permettent finalement de faire oublier
la continuité de ce gouvernement et de
sa ligne politique vraisembablement et
d'attirer là il des commentateurs ces
récents mois la plus grande surprise
c'est la nomination au poste de garde
des sceaux de monsieur dupont moretti
éventuellement un moindre degré celle de
madame bachelot à la culture quoique je
pense que très franchement c'est un set
un gouvernement qui encore une fois ne
traduit pas une rupture fondamentale
mais qui marque quand même que emmanuel
macron n'a pas réussi deux prises
politique à gauche pratiquement pas
aucune et qui s'inscrit plutôt dans une
ligne que je qualifierais de
conservatrice par fluide c'est que c'est
là qu'aujourd'hui résident
vraisemblablement son espace pour les
trois soirs boulot on va évidemment
rentrée un commentaire justement ces
nominations en tout cas pour les plus
importants des plus surprenantes
françois bonneau
son ensemble est ce que vous êtes
satisfait de ce nouveau gouvernement
bonsoir à tous je vais écouter je crois
que il faut déjà préciser qu'on commente
un événement on le sait puisque on
savait que les hommes à l'échangé on
n'est d'ailleurs pas surpris finalement
voir qu'il ya peu d'hommes qui ont
changé en réalité
mais quand bien même on les aurait tout
changé on change les hommes et pas la
politique ça qu'en fait on fait le
mercato le transfert de ministres entre
portefeuille ici et là mais la politique
ne va pas changer et va pas changer
parce que on feint de penser que le
pouvoir se situerait entre les mains du
gouvernement on est en 5ème république
qui depuis le quinquennat et bien a
transmis tous les pouvoirs à un seul et
même homme
c'est le prison un public donc le
pouvoir était à l'elysée c'est la
réalité regardons les choses en face
donc emmanuel macron va continuer la
même politique
donc là c'est le changement dans la
continuité que comme l'a dit arnaud
benedetti et finalement il faut pas se
laisser abuser par ces changements de
casting qui est qu'ils n'en sont pas et
on essaie de faire des coûts de
communication mais ça va pas changer sur
le fond la politique et donc ça ne va
pas changer la vie des gens et je crois
qu'il ya de plus en plus de gens
aujourd'hui dans le pays qui sont
désabusés de ces artifices de
communication et qui aimeraient qu'on
résolve plutôt leurs problèmes plutôt
que le remède des têtes de gondole en
affiche pour essayer de faire croire aux
gens qu'on est en train de faire quelque
chose pour eux alors à vos bd dit c'est
vrai que emmanuel macron irrégulier
encore quelques jours ensemble nous
traçons les contours de ce nouveau
chemin qui sera centré sur la
reconstruction économique social
environnemental et culturel de notre
pays on se souvient des discours d'
emmanuel macron juste après la crise du
coc vie de 19 un nouveau visage du
changement est ce que selon vous ce
gouvernement aujourd'hui est capable
d'un vrai tournant
dans la politique du président de la
république c'est extrêmement difficile
de le dire à ce stade mais en tout cas
les indications qui sont donnés par sa
composition ne préjuge pas d'un tournant
clairement les hommes disent quelque
part la politique est là en l'occurrence
re on voit qu'on est dans une ligne
encore une fois de continuité moi ce qui
me fera par contre c'est que finalement
le design communicants d'emmanuel macro
aujourd'hui est en quelque sorte en
rupture c'est qu' il ne peut même plus
en l'occurrence d'une certaine manière
faire fonctionner son en même temps donc
parce qu'il a tout simplement compris
que il avait vraisemblablement brûlé la
plupart de ces vaisseaux sur sa gauche
donc il investit de manière subliminale
et même pas séminal de manière assez
explicite un espace politique il est ce
lui disons des conservateurs de la
droite orléaniste et on voit que la
nomination de monsieur castex qui
remplace monsieur philippe obéit à cette
logique
il a vraisemblablement pris acte que il
fallait un email un électorat
conservateur à son entreprise politique
pour pouvoir finalement créer les
conditions d'un renouvellement de son
mandat en 2022 il fait un pari politique
de ce point de vue là sera-t-il ce pari
entendu ça c'est une autre question
parce que sur le fond je rejoins ce qu
est ce qu a dit monsieur boulot sous le
fond les fracturations de la société
française sont très fortes et finalement
l'autonomie du politique est relative
en l'occurrence et les problèmes
auxquels il va être confronté auquel son
executive est confronté ne seront
certainement pas résolu par un café
alors effectivement il fait le pari d
conservateur françois blot mais on sait
qu'il ya des dossiers chauds qui
attendent emmanuel macron dès la rentrée
d'ailleurs à commencer par celui des
retraites qui avait mis pas mal de monde
dans la rue au sujet de ces retraites
monsieur castex notre nouveau premier
ministre a dit qu'il voulait les
relancer dès l'été plus urgent de ségur
de la santé également
est ce que justement cette se maintient
ce du côté de la conservatrice est ce
que c'est vraiment ce qu'il fallait
aujourd'hui pour emmanuel macron pour
remonter justement cette cote de
popularité c'est qu'il ya deux prismes à
avoir ainsi si tu sors quand la
stratégie des menus mâcon oui c'est
plutôt une bonne stratégie il a pour
être élu en 2022 parce qu'il a pour lui
le soutien du bloc bourgeois c'est la
classe moyenne supérieure
c'est l'ancienne classe qui a voté pour
la droite et on a vu lors des élections
européennes
alors qu'il avait des électeurs de
gauche une partie des électeurs de
gauche
en 2017 il ya eu une bascule et il a
plutôt capter les électeurs de droite
lors des élections européennes ont
finalement on est dans la dynamique qui
se poursuit aujourd'hui l'a bien compris
qu'en gros il avait beaucoup plus de
soin d'être élu par le bloc
à droite le bloc de droite peu
conservateur traditionnel pour 2022 nous
sur deux sont de vue là c'est une bonne
stratégie électoraliste pour amener à
mâcon mais après il ya l'autre point de
vue en fait cessé c'est celui qu'on peut
avoir quand on est un citoyen quand on
est soucieux de l'intérêt général
quand on est soucieux de l'avenir de
notre pays quand on est soucieux de
l'avenir des gens qui vivent dans ce
pays il ya toujours aujourd'hui 9
millions de pauvres dans notre pays et
c'est le chiffre augmente d'année en
année il ya 150 milles ldf enfin on sait
que l'état du pays né est extrêmement
précaire fragile pour beaucoup de
personnes
et on sait que la catastrophe économique
arrive est d'ailleurs emmanuel macron
l'a confirmé il va y avoir des faillites
qui vont continuer qui vont se
poursuivre et ça va être un cataclysme à
la rentrée dans ce cadre là la question
qui posez c'est est ce qu'on fait comme
avant c'est à dire une politique qui a
conduit à la montée des inégalités et un
chômage de masse à une
désindustrialisation massive dans le
pays où est-ce qu'on change enfin de
politique le problème c'est que jean
castex
il a déjà donné des éléments de réponse
alors effectivement avec la question de
la réforme des retraites
il explique que il va essayer de la
faire passer très rapidement et dans les
termes sur les grandes lignes qui seront
exactement les mêmes que la réforme dont
les sondages ont montré qu'elles étaient
rejetées par quasiment deux tiers de
l'opinion publique t il s'est présenté
par ce qu on fait de la communication ne
change pas le fond s'est présenté comme
un gaulliste un gaulliste social
sauf qu'il n'est ni gaulliste ni sociale
cerc eux ils ne croient pas en l'état
parce que juste après avoir décrété
gaulliste social il expliqué que pour
l'état ne pouvait pas tout 1 qu'il
fallait on appela responsabilité
individuelle de chacun bon bah ça c'est
la définition du libéralisme économique
donc c'est tout sauf gaulliste le
gaullisme c'est justement un état
extrêmement fort un état
interventionniste dans l'économie puis
par ailleurs il n'est pas social puisque
il a repris la ritournelle des libéraux
c'est à dire il faut d'abord produire la
richesse et ensuite la redistribuer
alors je conteste pas le principe mais
ce sont sept jours derrière ce principe
que les libéraux se cachent pour ne pas
changer la clé de répartition des
richesses et donc ne pas changer le
régime fiscal applicable ne pas lutter
contre l'évasion fiscale bref ne pas
changer contre les règles qui font que
les ultra-riches de ce pays capte très
largement les richesses qui sont
produites
et alors que l'on a une richesse qui
devrait aujourd'hui est donc être
répartie beaucoup plus équitablement
ce qui n'est pas qu'un donc on va avoir
la même politique libérale et qui va
continuer à s'appliquer malheureusement
je vais vous faire écouter quelques
réactions les premières à la suite de ce
nouveau gouvernement
les annonces en tout cas de ce nouveau
gouvernement écouter un gouvernement
libéral banal castanet rb loubet honte
de l'intérieur et de la justice
enfin démissionner darmana et dupond
moretti doivent rétablir la dignité et
l'honneur à la justice est nommé un
militant d'extrême gauche qui souhaite
l'interdiction du rassemblement national
premier parti d'opposition
ça promet si bête et castaner dehors
petit bonheur du soir
pour le reste on reprend largement les
mêmes et on recommence et je m'attends à
une belle pagaille à la justice avec
dupond moretti
de toute façon tous européiste donc zéro
changement possible les français
voulaient changer de politique et garder
le même premier ministre emmanuel macron
a fait exactement l'inversé
il change le premier ministre mais avec
ce nouveau gouvernement
on comprend qu'il n'y aura pas de
changement politique est l'une des
réactions qu'on retiendra arnaud
benedetti celle de marine le pen
concernant eric dupond-moretti elle dit
de lui voilà on a mis finalement la
justice un militant d'extrême gauche qui
voient supprimer le premier parti
d'opposition en france c'est-à-dire son
parti le rassemblement national est ce
que vous partagez ce diagnostic de
marine le pen
non je ne suis pas sûr que monsieur
dupont moretti veut supprimer le
rassemblement national mais le problème
de monsieur dupont moretti c'est que
d'abord c'est quelqu'un qui a énormément
de talent et chacun s'accorde à lui
reconnaître qu'il est un grand avocat
qu'il appartient à cette tradition du
verbe des des prétoires qui est
incontestable la difficulté c'est que le
tempérament de monsieur dupont moretti
va-t-il pouvoir se mouvoir dans la
fonction de garde des sceaux on sait que
c'est quelqu'un de particulièrement
électif qui a des positions qui sont
parfois d'ailleurs justifié mais
extrêmement clivante
il va avoir à gérer également le corps
des magistrats
donc c'est extrêmement difficile pour un
ministre de la justice d'être
dans une situation qui risque d'être
dans une situation de le mettre dans une
situation conflictuelle
donc il y a indéniablement si vous
voulez de la part d' emmanuel macron la
volonté d'aller chercher quelqu'un dont
on reconnaît à la fois le charisme les
compétences et le talent mais qui
vraisemblablement ce sera plutôt
difficile à gérer politiquement à
contrôler politiquement parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui lui a une grande autonomie
personnelle et qui vraisemblablement ne
se laissera pas dicter sa conduite donc
il ya au delà du coup de com' plutôt
réussie en l'occurrence une zone de
risque pour le président de la
république et pour le premier ministre
en désignant monsieur dupont moretti à
la chancellerie
voilà pour eric dupond-moretti autres
nominations qui attire l'attention
évidemment celle de gérald arman à
l'intérieur la place de christophe
castaner françois boulot vous l'avocat
des gilet jaune on sait que christophe
castaner a été beaucoup critiqué pour sa
gestion des manifestations évidemment le
préfet l'allemand encore plus à paris
mais avec les ordres du ministre est ce
que c'est une bonne chose pour vous ce
remplacement par le sarkozyste gérald
darmanin
je crois que rien ne va changer et
darmanin il était déjà au gouvernement
et puis par ailleurs castaner ne faisait
qu'appliquer les consignes des manuels
macro encore une fois vous avez un
pouvoir qui mène une politique qui la
mène de façon brutale il brutalise les
gens parce que la plupart des réformes
qui ont posé problème a été rejetée
majoritairement dans le pays emmanuel
macron n'en a que faire
il y passe en force et pour ça eh bien
il a besoin de la police effectivement
d'instrumentaliser la police parce qu'on
l'a vu il ya eu les gilet jaune
évidemment il ya eu la grève contre la
réforme des retraites
bref il ya eu des mouvements de
contestation extrêmement important et
qu'il a fallu canaliser qu'angers
canaliser en fait il a fallu brutaliser
les citoyens dans les manifestations les
mettre en garde à vue prononcer des
condamnations judiciaires etc bref c'est
une stratégie du pouvoir et stratégies
qui est dit est piloté dirigé par ml
mâcon donc darmana cap
ou un autre ça ne va rien changer voyez
je ne crois pas que gérald darmanin
il a un grand projet en tant que nice de
l'intérieur de réformer par exemple igpn
a brillé alors que pourtant on sait très
bien que c'est un organisme et outils
dans beaucoup de dossiers travail plutôt
à nettoyer les preuves à ne pas écouter
les témoins qui serait pourtant
déterminant dans telle ou telle affaire
de violences policières
donc non gérald darmanin ça ne va rien
changer quant à eric dupond moretti et
même si je garde un devoir de réserve
évidemment parce que il ya une heure ou
deux il était encore l'un de mes
confrères sur le plan déontologique la
courtoisie commande qu'on compte ce
critique pas mais je suis très curieux
de voir quelle position il va prendre
premièrement par rapport à la réforme
des retraites parce que cette réforme
elle peut impacter très fortement les
cabinets d'avocats et notamment les
petits cabinets d'avocats dont beaucoup
risquent de mourir
tout simplement à cause de réforme des
retraites parce que le taux de
cotisation va exploser donc à de cette
réforme
ensuite je suis curieux de voir sa
position sur l'indépendance de la
justice parce qu'on a vu effectivement
notamment les pressions qui ont été
exercées par les la magistrate du
parquet national financiers sur ces
magistrats subordonnés et puis également
évidemment sa position sur l'aspect
d'une liberté fondamentale puisque on a
vu qu'il ait pris position notamment sur
les écoutes téléphoniques bon bref on va
voir tout ça je suis curieux parce que
j'ai l'impression qu'il met les pieds
dans un cadre soit qu'il n'a pas compris
ne soit dont ils ne voient pas les
conséquences
mais en tout état de cause je ne vois
pas un seul instant emmanuel macron lui
donner carte blanche pour réformer la
justice dans un sens plus respectueux
des libertés à emmanuel macron a fait la
preuve de tout le contraire qui ont
finalement les le respect des libertés
individuelles
ça lui importait peu et on a vu que ces
libertés ont été bafoués dans le cadre
du mouvement de gilet jaune
merci françois hollande